Guten Morgen, Linus.
Guten Morgen, Tim.
Sag mal, kannst du mir mal das Förmchen reichen?
Tim, du hast hier nicht die Karten auf der Hand. Du musst mal ganz schön dankbar
sein. Du spielst hier mit dem Dritten Weltkrieg.
Logbuch-Netzpolitik Nummer 517 vom 18.
Oder 19. März 2025.
Man weiß es nicht so genau, je nachdem, welcher Zeitzone man gerade so lebt
oder in welcher Zeitenwende man gerade so ist.
Unterschiedliche Zeitzonen haben unterschiedliche Zeitenwenden.
Wichtig ist, dass wir beide in der gleichen Faktenzone sind.
Ja, das wäre auf jeden Fall ganz gut. Mal gucken, wie sich das heute so ergibt.
Da gibt es die GMF Greenwich Mean Facts. Das ist das, was wir...
Das ist sozusagen da, wo alles austariert ist.
Von da kannst du plus zwölf oder minus zwölf.
Und das ist auch so eine Meinungslinie, die ziehen wir jetzt hier einfach mal
mitten durch unseren Podcast durch, zwischen Tim und Linus sozusagen.
Da verläuft die Meinungslinie.
Dazwischen, da kann man, das ist eine Zone, da kannst du ein bisschen nach rechts,
ein bisschen nach links, aber danach bist du einfach in einer anderen Faktion.
Das ist quasi unsere Definition von politischer Mitte. Zwischen dir und mir.
Und Fakten.
Wir sind das auch nicht immer einer. Das ist definitiv auch so ein Aspekt.
Das ist eine Faktenzone. Da drin gibt es abweichende Meinungen und außerhalb sind die anderen.
Das ist der Feind. Den müssen wir bekämpfen.
Okay, klares Feindbild hier schon mal aufgestellt. Die Sendung läuft ja gut los.
Aber willst du ja, die Linie verläuft zwischen oben und unten,
Tim, und nichts zwischen dir.
Meinst du? Mal gucken, was dabei rauskommt. Oh Mann, oh Mann.
Ja, jetzt hatten wir ein paar Sendungen, die, wo wir nicht gemeinsam am Mikrofon
waren, sagen wir es mal so.
Und jetzt müssen wir uns erstmal wieder hier einordnen. Du bist ja ein bisschen
Bus gefahren, ich bin hier in Asien unterwegs und in der Zwischenzeit ist eine
ganze Menge Feedback auf uns zugelaufen,
wo wir noch gar nicht so richtig die Zeit hatten, das aufzugreifen.
Deswegen wollen wir das heute mal ein bisschen machen.
Wunderbar, ja.
Ja, geht's los hier mit der Sendung vor einem Monat?
Also wir hatten am Ende der Sendung die letzte Bundestagsrede von Anke Domscheid-Berg eingespielt.
Und darauf bezieht sich der andere Tim.
Eure Die Linke-Wahlwerbesendung hat anscheinend funktioniert bei dem Wahlergebnis.
Also ja, kommen wir später. Ich bin gelinde gesagt irritiert,
dass Tim das so mitträgt.
Jede Stimme für diese Partei ist eine Stimme für Putin und gegen Ukraine und
andere osteuropäische Länder.
Mag ja sein, dass Tim es in seiner aktuellen Phase der allgemeinen Lethargie
nicht wahrhaben will, aber dieser Podcast hat natürlich Einfluss und am Ende
habt ihr möglicherweise dabei geholfen,
den einen oder anderen Sitz im Parlament gegen die Ukraine und gegen die NATO zu richten.
Jeder hat seine begrenzte und vermeintlich unbedeutende Möglichkeit, Einfluss zu nehmen.
Ob euer Einfluss von euch leichtfertig oder bewusst indirekt gegen Ukraine und
gegen NATO gerichtet ist, kann ich nicht sagen.
Ich werde aber meinen unbedeutenden Beitrag in Form von finanzieller Unterstützung
dieses Podcast einstellen.
Ich will damit nichts zu tun haben. Gruß der andere Tim.
Okay.
Also konsequent.
Ja.
Also zunächst einmal möchte ich dazu sagen, also die Wahrnehmung,
dass unser Bonustrack sozusagen in dieses Podcast in irgendeiner Form in der
Lage wäre, die deutsche Bundespolitik dahingehend zu beeinflussen,
dass es irgendwie darüber entscheidet,
ob Parteien in den Bundestag kommen oder nicht,
halte ich für ein bisschen, naja, etwas spitz formuliert.
Also ich sehe diesen Einfluss nicht.
Also nicht, dass wir keinen Einfluss haben in irgendeiner Form, aber bestimmt nicht so.
Und von daher, ja okay, gut.
Und wie man jetzt zu der Linken steht, das muss halt jeder selber wissen.
Ich denke, was überhaupt jetzt von der Linken, von der Fraktion,
die jetzt gewählt worden ist, zu sehen sein wird und zu erwarten ist,
wissen wir alle noch nicht so richtig.
Weil das jetzt ja eigentlich sozusagen das erste Mal dieses Neuaufstellen der
Partei ist, nachdem sich dieser hochproblematische BSW-Teil davon abgespalten hat, der, glaube ich,
gerade in der Perspektive des Kommentierenden hier das eigentliche Problem war.
Ob das dann immer noch so ist, das weiß ich nicht, das wird man sehen.
Davon abgesehen, also ich meine,
ganz ehrlich, wir haben natürlich hier unsere Meinung, wir sind auch nicht unbedingt
immer einer Meinung, auch wenn wir gerade den Meridian neu abgesteckt haben.
Aber es geht ja hier auch nicht darum, immer nur eine einzige Haltung einzunehmen
und nur eine universelle Weltsicht abzubilden,
sondern die Welt und die Wahrheit und die Realität ist halt einfach kompliziert
und da gibt es verschiedenste Meinungen, die man berücksichtigen muss.
Nicht unbedingt jede, aber zumindest mehr als eine und zumindest mehr als unsere beiden.
Und das muss dann auch in diesem Podcast auch mal Raum haben.
Wir trauen euch auf jeden Fall zu, eure eigene Meinung zu haben und zu entwickeln.
Und wenn wir dazu was beitragen können, dass die sich besser bildet und entwickelt,
dann macht uns das natürlich froh.
Und J. Fischer hat in dem Kontext kommentiert,
Also ich kürze mal so ein bisschen was raus, weil er auch zum anderen Aspekt was sagt.
Jetzt mal im Ernst, ich höre euer Format jetzt schon seit Jahren und fand es
immer sehr angenehm, dass ihr den Menschen viele wichtige Informationen bereitsteht,
aber nicht ständig versucht, allen zu erklären, wie sie die Welt zu sehen haben.
Wir Hörer dürfen selber denken und entscheiden, was wir daraus machen. Gut so.
Das wäre mein wichtiger Punkt.
Wir haben tatsächlich auch vor der Veröffentlichung der Sendung diskutiert,
ob man diesen Wahlempfehlungswunsch, den Anker am Ende der Rede macht,
rausschneidet, aber das wäre genauso lächerlich gewesen.
Und ich glaube, ich kann jedem Menschen, der in der Lage ist,
diesen Podcast zu subscriben und anzuhören, traue ich durchaus zu,
alles, was hier gesagt wird, einzuordnen.
Und in den Kommentaren sehen wir ja auch, dass das passiert.
Da gibt es auch zum Beispiel sehr unterschiedliche Meinungen dazu,
ob wir jetzt auf Ankes Kommentar richtig oder falsch reagiert haben.
J. Fischer, den ich gerade hier zitiert habe, sagt zum Beispiel,
wenn jetzt die Podcaster Sorge haben, dass sie nicht genug getan haben,
um die Leistung einzelner Politiker zu bewerben, dann graust mir jetzt schon
vor dem Versuch, das umzusetzen.
Hier ist ein Problem wer könnte was tun oder gibt es noch was von den Linken
also ganz ehrlich Leute wir machen diesen Podcast seit 516 Episoden und ich
glaube genauso wie wir hier mal zum Beispiel mit Ulrike Franke euch ein bisschen
auf die Probe gestellt haben,
werdet ihr auch eine Wahl eine Bundestagsrede von Anke Domscheid-Berg,
verkraften,
Und wir werden auch verkraften, dass dann mal eine finanzielle Unterstützung
für dieses Projekt einbricht.
Der Stockmarket ist ja auch im Keller. Ich muss demnächst wieder irgendwo putzen gehen.
Aber das kriegen wir alles hinter uns, Leute.
Das schaffen wir.
Und dazu muss ich auch noch anfügen, Anker ist auch aktiv irgendwie pro Ukraine
und hat selber ukrainische Flüchtlinge geholfen und Projekte aufgesetzt und so weiter.
Also die ist ja überhaupt auch nicht auch nur im Ansatz verdächtig,
da irgendwie ein Problem zu sein.
Ach, das haben wir gar nicht erzählt, Tim.
Wir hatten ja, guck mal, wir hatten doch mal hier zu Beginn des Krieges,
hatten wir ja hier Geld gesammelt, um die Wohnung zu bezahlen,
in der wir die Familie, die geflüchtet war,
aus der Ukraine untergebracht haben.
Und dann haben wir ja diese Zurückzahlung bekommen, weil der Staat dann das
übernommen hat. Weil der Staat das bezahlt hat.
Und dann hatten wir auf einmal dieses Geld und dann hatte ich schwere Not,
das irgendwo unterzubringen.
Und das ist dann an ein Projekt vom Verstehbahnhof gegangen,
der ja von Anke Domscheitberg und Daniel Domscheitberg gemacht wird.
Ich erinnere mich, da haben die nämlich diese Künstlerinnen,
Kunstschülerinnen aus Scharkiv gehabt.
Insofern super, ein anderer Tim. Das Risiko, dass wir damit Geflüchtete aus
der Ukraine unterstützen mit eurem Geld, hast du jetzt minimiert.
Genau.
Trotzdem, ich finde das...
Auch richtig, hier ein klares Bekenntnis, das werden wir im weiteren Verlauf
der Sendung sicherlich noch mehr behandeln,
dazu zu haben, wer in dieser Situation Aggressor ist und wer nicht und wer Unterstützung
verdient hat und wer nicht.
Und ich glaube, da ist die Positionierung von Tim und von mir hoffentlich sonnenklar
und wird es auch im weiteren Verlauf dieser Sendung sicherlich nochmal sein.
Und wenn wir hier mal einer Person, die sich über viele Jahre im Bereich der
Digitalpolitik verdient gemacht hat, Raum geben.
Wie übrigens, wir haben ja auch hier den leider verstorbenen Hans-Christian Ströbele,
der auch die eine oder andere Position hatte, die zu einem oder anderen Thema
den Leuten nicht gefallen hat, der zum Beispiel auch RAF-Terroristen verteidigt.
Auch das war ja in weiteren Kommentaren hier nochmal Thema.
Ich sehe mich darin bestätigt, hier ab und zu mal ein paar andere Perspektiven mit einzubringen.
So, dann gab es aber von dir noch deinen schwärmerischen Ausflug über J.D.
Vance, den fandst du ja richtig geil, weil er ja so ein guter Redner ist.
Er ist ein guter Redner.
Hast du gesagt.
Ja, dazu kommentiert RSS nur ganz kurz zu J.D. Vance angeblichen Redequalitäten.
Ich vermute, er kann nur sehr gut von den zwei Text-Telepromptern links und
rechts neben dem Rednerpult ablesen,
die sieht man zumindest deutlich im Mitschnitt und sein konstantes Kopfschweifen
nach links und rechts deutet ebenfalls darauf hin.
Mag sein, habe ich nicht gesehen, ich gucke bei Videos nicht hin,
aber mag auch sein, dass er diese Rede vom Teleprompter abgelesen hat,
aber wenn wir mal davon ausgehen, dass das gleiche auf Olaf Scholz und sonstige
zu treffen würde, hat das trotzdem besser gemacht.
Ja, aber das machen alle Amerikaner besser. Also das ist überhaupt nichts Besonderes jetzt von J.D.
Vance, sondern das amerikanische Schulsystem ist sicherlich auch das eine oder
andere Kritikwürdige dabei,
aber generell wird dort im Unterricht
halt diese freie Rede als normales Stilmittel sehr viel verwendet.
Die Bait Club ist dann Standard, eine Standard Extracurricular Activity.
Kannst irgendwie laufen, Orchester spielen, Marching-Band spielen, Debate-Club.
Und dann wird dir gesagt, was du zu debattieren hast.
Dann hast du Vorbereitungszeit und dann musst du halt eine Rede dafür halten. Also das stimmt.
Genau. Und das ist halt in Deutschland nicht so, hier ist immer noch Hefte raus
und alles muss aufgeschrieben werden und so weiter. Wir leben halt da auch immer
noch so ein bisschen in den Zeiten des...
Der Dampfmaschine. Das ist eine Dampfmaschine. Und so wird das halt hier auch nix.
Also ich finde das ist ja so. Ich bin ja eh gerade ein bisschen so anti-deutsch
unterwegs. Ich finde alles ganz furchtbar.
Wenn du anti-deutsch hast, hast du irgendeine Begriff bedeutet?
Ja, nein, Entschuldigung, das war das falsche Wort.
Verlieren wir die nächsten Spender? Kannst du nicht, ey. Als nächstes haben
wir hier noch die Nahostkonflikt in der Sitzung.
Ja, okay, das wollen wir natürlich nicht.
Kommen wir zu den anderen Fehlern, die ich gemacht habe. Als ich mit,
Thomas über die Bundestagswahl geredet habe, habe ich natürlich dann auch so
ein bisschen über diese Wahlrechtsreform geredet und hatte natürlich wieder keine Ahnung.
Aber ist ja immer super, ne? Keine Ahnung und dann redet man einfach ins Internet
rein und mit seiner Keinen Ahnung und dann kannst du schon wirklich die Uhr danach stellen.
Aber hier Wahlempfehlungen machen oder was?
Ja, pfff, klar. So, ja, also ich hab halt, ich weiß gar nicht mehr so ganz genau, was ich gesagt habe.
Ich hab irgendwas vorgeschlagen, wie man es auch eigentlich machen sollte und
das wird auch viel besser, als so, wie ich dachte, wie es funktioniert und das
hab ich natürlich alles überhaupt nicht hinbekommen.
Also, erster Kommentar kam von Esther.
Doch, genau so funktioniert das neue Wahlrecht. Erstmal gehen die Mandate von der Liste ab.
Genau, das habe ich nämlich vorgeschlagen, warum man denn das nicht mal macht,
weil ich es halt einfach nicht verstanden habe.
Nur wenn man die CSU ist und bundesweit so circa 5% bekommt,
in Bayern aber fast alle Direktmandate bekommt, wird die gesamte Liste gestrichen
und es werden immer noch zu viele Mandate.
Dann werden die knappsten Direktmandate gestrichen.
Soweit ich das verstanden habe, funktioniert das neue Wahlsystem nach dem folgenden Algorithmus.
Erstens, die Leute mit Direktmandaten werden nach Erfolg bei den Erststimmen
sortiert in die eigentliche Liste vorne eingefügt.
Zweitens, von dieser neuen Liste bekommen so viele Leute ein Mandat,
wie es dem Zweitstimmenanteil der Partei entspricht.
Dass Leute trotz gewonnenem Wahlkreis kein Mandat bekommen, ist also eher der
Edge-Case, wenn eine Partei anteilsmäßig deutlich mehr Direktmandate als zwei
Stimmen bekommt und zwar um einen Faktor größer zwei.
Dazu gibt es, by the way, auch eine Parlamentsrevue, in der das en detail erklärt wird.
Selbstverständlich gibt es die. Hätte ich natürlich auch vorher mal hören sollen.
Machen wir uns eigentlich auch immer. Habe ich aber nicht, weil ich irgendwie auf Reisen bin.
Und passenderweise kam dann auch gleich noch Sabrina von der Parlamentsrevue.
Hallo Sabrina, die war ja auch schon mal hier.
Und schreibt gleich hinterher, danke Esther, das wollte ich auch gerade schreiben.
Und ich möchte noch ergänzen, die sogenannte Grundmandatsklausel,
dass eine Partei in den Bundestag anzieht, wenn sie drei Direktmandate gewonnen
hat, besteht weiterhin.
Die wurde zwar durch die Wahlrechtsreform abgeschafft, das Verfassungsgericht
hat die Regelung aber vorerst wieder in Kraft gesetzt.
Daher auch die Mission Silberlocke mit Link auf dieses... Oh Gott!
Was tun wir hier eigentlich? Das ist eine Wahlwärmesendung.
Also erst war es ein Wahlrecht falsch erklärt, dann die falsche Partei empfohlen.
Katastrophen, so ein Podcast.
Sabrina, Mensch.
Genau. GR09 schmeißt noch mal ein bisschen was hinterher, noch einen Stein.
Dass die Aussagen zum neuen Wahlrecht großer Blödsinn waren,
wurde oben schon ausführlich kommentiert.
Kurzzusammenfassung. Die Überhangsmandate und Ausgleichsmandate fallen weg.
Überhangsmandate waren, wenn eine Partei mehr Begleiterscheinungen als Sitze
hat und gar niemand über die Liste mehr reinkommt.
Das und der notwendige Ausgleich haben den Bundestag aufgebläht.
Jetzt wird der Bundestag auch auf 630 Sitze fixiert und die Überhangsmandate
mit den schlechtesten Ergebnissen kommen halt nicht mehr rein. So, Punkt.
Sag mal, Begleiterscheinung, das klingt irgendwie nach irgendeinem Autocorrect, oder? Mehr,
Weitstimmen.
Lassen wir das. Nächster Kommentar.
Wenn alles irgendwie durch den AI-Slop hier durchläuft, dann betrifft das halt auch unseren Podcast.
Aber,
mehr,
Also wir haben, also nächste Kommentare.
Auf jeden Fall viele Erläuterungen dazu. Achso, und dann habt ihr euch über
Taiwan und China unterhalten.
Genau. Ja, dazu gab es ein paar kluge, gab es eine ganze Reihe von Kommentaren,
die ich lese hier auf gar keinen Fall alle vor, könnt ihr gerne nachholen.
Ich habe ja auch keine Ahnung.
Ich meine, ich bin da jetzt irgendwie aufgelaufen, habe ein paar Tage das Land
kennengelernt, war es dann im Wesentlichen auch schon.
Aber Stefan trug noch nach. Zur Einnahme Taiwans durch China finde ich drei Punkte interessant.
Da die Republik China kein anerkannter Staat mehr ist, ist das völkerrechtlich
schwer mit der Ukraine vergleichbar. Hatten wir natürlich gemacht.
Fast alle Staaten sagen, dass es nur ein China gäbe. Also können sie das schon
mal nicht als völkerrechtswidrigen Angriffskrieg verurteilen.
Auch die Republik China, also Taiwan, sagt im Prinzip, es gibt nur ein China,
nur die legitime Regierung sitzt eben in Taipei und nicht in Peking.
Taipei beansprucht wie auch Peking das südchinesische Meer für China.
Diese Idee gab es schon in der Kaiserzeit, bevor es internationale Regeln zu
internationalen Gewässern gab.
Zweitens, Peking hat mehrmals in den 50ern versucht, die Insel einzunehmen und
ist trotz massiver Überlegenheit immer gescheitert.
Selbst wenn Peking es schafft, die Insel einzunehmen, ist es fraglich,
ob sie überhaupt etwas davon hätten, wenn die Chipfabriken dadurch zerstört
oder vertrieben werden.
Das wäre ein rein ideologischer Sieg. Die Chipfabriken brauchen dann auch noch
die Fertigungstechnik aus den USA und der EU, die wäre dann aber auch abgeschnitten
und nach so einer Aktion würde ich eher mehr als weniger Exportverbote erwarten.
Ja, also ihr seht schon, das ist ein sehr umstrittenes Thema,
so wie diese ganze Taiwan-Situation zu beurteilen ist.
Ich belasse es auch mal dabei. Wie gesagt, es waren noch sehr viele andere kluge
Kommentare dort zu finden. Könnt ihr dort nochmal nachschlagen.
Gibt auf jeden Fall da viele Meinungen zu.
Ich würde in dem Kontext nur gerne noch kurz empfehlen, die Logbuch-Netzpolitik-Folge 280,
Wolkensensorik und die Logbuch-Netzpolitik-Folge 374, Ein alter weißer Mann
ist passiert, wo wir die Katharin Tai zu Gast hatten.
Einmal, glaube ich, zu China mit einer etwas allgemeineren Perspektive und dann
zu Corona-Maßnahmen in China, Taiwan und dem asiatischen Bereich.
Die kennt sich mit dem Land, in dem du da bist, ein bisschen besser aus als ich und du.
So, und dann müssen wir aber auch noch nachreichen.
Das wurde dann in den Kommentaren auch hinterfragt und es war ja auch mein erstes
Feedback zu dir, nachdem du die letzte Sendung gemacht hast.
Warum zur Hölle habt ihr nicht erklärt, warum dieser Bus Adenauer SRP Plus heißt?
Ich dachte, das wäre Basiswissen.
Also mein Basiswissen Ehrlich gesagt war das nicht und ich glaube,
das wäre auf jeden Fall meine erste Frage gewesen.
Anyway, es gibt ja die FAQ auf der Adenauer.de.
Dort steht, warum heißt der Gefängnistransporter für die AfD Adenauer SRP Plus?
Antwort. Der Zusatz SRP Plus ist eine Anspielung auf die erste rechtsextreme
Partei, die in der Bundesrepublik jemals verboten wurde.
Diese Erfolgsstory der Demokratie ist ein leuchtendes Beispiel für ihre Verteidigung.
Die Sozialistische Reichspartei SRP wurde 1952 nach nur zehn Verhandlungstagen
als erste rechtsextreme Partei in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland verboten.
Die SRP war, wie die Alternative für Deutschland, einigermaßen Ein Wiederbelebungsversuch
der Ideologie der NSDAP, der mit scharfen rechtlichen Maßnahmen unter der Führung
des Bundesinnenministers Robert Lehr von der CDU gestoppt wurde.
Lehr war Teil des Kabinetts des damaligen Bundeskanzlers Konrad Adenauer.
Das Verbot der SAP war ein Meilenstein für die wehrhafte Demokratie und ein
klares Zeichen, dass rechtsextreme Hitze in Deutschland keinen Platz hat.
Das Plus steht für die Erweiterung dieses Geistes in unsere Zeit.
Der SRP Plus ist mehr als nur eine Erinnerung an die Erfolge der wehrhaften
Demokratie der 50er Jahre.
Er symbolisiert den modernen Einsatz für die Verteidigung demokratischer Werte.
Indem er Hightech, öffentlichkeitswirksame Aktionen und klare Beweisführung
verbindet, um gegen die Verfassungsfeindlichkeit der AfD vorzugehen.
Mit dem Adenauer SRP Plus wird nicht nur an die historische Bedeutung des SRP-Verbots
erinnert, sondern gleichzeitig die Notwendigkeit unterstrichen,
auch heute entschieden gegen rechtsextreme Bedrohungen vorzugehen.
Und zwar bevor es zu spät ist.
Und wir alle wissen ja, welchen Stellenwert Konrad Adenauer für die CDU hat.
Und entsprechend ist natürlich ein sehr schöner Name, der aber ja auch Erläuterungen braucht.
Ich habe es auch nicht sofort gewusst.
So, so. Jetzt ist es raus.
So, damit wären wir in einer, es ist ja einiges passiert in den letzten Wochen.
Dinge, wo mir wirklich, ja, ich dachte,
bei der, die Vans-Rede bei der Münchner Sicherheitskonferenz war schon so ungefähr
das Irrste, was ich je gesehen habe.
Ich würde sagen, dass das wirklich das wirklich Irrste, was ich in lange,
lange, lange, lange Zeit gesehen habe, war dann diese Situation,
als der ukrainische Präsident Volodymyr Zelensky in die USA gereist ist, im Weißen Haus ist,
um mehr oder weniger zu unterschreiben, dass die USA jetzt sämtliche Bodenschätze
dieses Landes ausbeuten dürfen.
Als Dankeschön dafür, dass sie das Land unterstützt haben mit Waffen.
Und es ergibt sich dort eine Situation, die sicherlich alle schon gesehen haben.
Wenn nicht, das sollte man sich schon durchaus angeschaut haben.
Wo J.D. Vance irgendwie sowas sagt im Sinne von, ja, und die Diplomatie und so.
Und da müsste jetzt einfach mal der Zelensky muss jetzt mal langsam ein bisschen
was in die Diplomatie gehen.
In eine Positionierung, die ja übrigens auch, denke ich, unserem ehemaligen
Unterstützer, dem anderen Tim, durchaus aufstoßen würde und auch für mich eine
absolute Unverschämtheit ist.
Und da können wir dann sehen, wie Volodymy Selensky auch in Anwesenheit dieser
beiden Clowns dann da die Hutstur platzt und er dann einfach mal fragt,
ob er vielleicht nochmal erläutern könnte, von welcher Diplomatie hier die Rede ist.
Dass, wenn die Ukraine seit Jahren militärisch von Russland angegriffen wird,
andauernd gesagt hat, okay, können wir irgendwie reden und alles,
was ihnen gesagt wurde, war, können wir mich mal im Arsch lecken.
Und dann,
wird er in einem Tonfall, der unvorstellbar ist auf dem internationalen diplomatischen Parkett,
davon Vance und Trump irgendwie gedemütigt und zurechtgewiesen.
Und das Ganze endet damit, dass er das Weiße Haus verlässt und die ganze Welt sieht,
wie die USA einem Verbündeten in einem Ausmaß in den Rücken fallen,
dass wirklich jeder Beschreibung einfach nur spöttet.
Ich bin auch heute noch sprachlos, was da vorgeführt wurde und was da an Vertrauen.
Im guten wie auch im schlechten Sinne darauf,
dass die USA und wie die USA mit ihrer Macht umgehen, zerstört wurde.
Ich meine auch wirklich Vertrauen von Verbündeten und auch Vertrauen von Gegnern.
Also in Russland, ich kann mir gar nicht, die müssen ja überlegt haben,
ob das ein Deepfake ist, ob die verarscht werden.
Ob die quasi jetzt irgendwie, also wenn du da irgendwie Wladimir Putin bist
und du siehst das, du kommst doch vor Lachen nicht in den Schlaf.
Also es ist ja unvorstellbarer, unvorstellbar.
Ja, das ist so ein weiterer Erfolg der russischen Propagandaschmiede, kann man sagen.
Also ich meine, die beschränkten mentalen Fähigkeiten von Trump sind ja nun
offensichtlich seit vielen, vielen Jahren und der erzählt auch immer nur gerade
das, was ihm irgendwie als letztes hintenrum erzählt wurde.
Das Ganze gepaart mit seiner Bewunderung für so mafiöse Menschen und dem eigentlichen
Kerninteresse, was er selbst ist.
Das alles zusammen führt dann halt dazu.
Und das war natürlich ein vorbereiteter Coup an der Stelle.
Also ich meine, das Ganze, das war ein totales Setup. Das fing ja schon vorher an.
Allein schon damit, dass quasi normalerweise ja solche Presserunden eher after
the fact sind, nachdem irgendwas unterschrieben ist und dann wird da nochmal
drüber geredet. Hier wurde das ja quasi umgedreht.
Und es fing ja schon vorher an mit diesem Typen,
also einem angeblichen Journalisten, der also eigentlich so ein rechter Blogger
ist und irgendwie der Freund von Moskau Marjorie, Marjorie Taylor Greene.
Der dann irgendwie sich erstmal darüber nochmal markiert hat,
dass ja der Zelensky gar keinen Anzug tragen würde und was denn hier mit dem Respekt vor.
Ja, aber damit wurde das sozusagen eingeleitet und das zeigt halt auch relativ
klar, okay, das war also alles so ein abgesprochenes Ding.
Dann kam halt J.D. Vance und meinte irgendwie, er müsste sich ja mal bedanken bei den USA.
Ich meine, der Zelensky hat sich im laufenden Meter bedankt.
Es gibt irgendwie 31 dokumentierte Danksagungen von ihm auf allen möglichen Kanälen.
Und ja, dann führte das halt irgendwie zu diesem Eklat.
Die Trumpsche Methode ist halt irgendwie, wie er so seine Deals immer gemacht hat.
Also maximalen Druck ausüben und ohne Rücksicht auf Verluste und wie das halt
so im Businessbereich, zumindest in seinem Businessbereich normalerweise eben so abläuft, aber ohne,
dass in irgendeiner Form diplomatische Gepflogenheiten da eine große Rolle spielen,
noch dass halt die Auswirkungen dieses Handelns, die das auf die Welt hat.
In irgendeiner Form mit eingepreist sind.
Das ist denen halt irgendwie total egal. Und gestützt durch diese, also J.D.
Vance steht ja für mich eben für diesen neuen Technofaschismus von Elon Musk
und Peter Thiel und diesen ganzen anderen problematischen Figuren,
dieser Tech-Bubble, Marc Andresen, der irgendwie mal diesen NetScape Navigator gemacht hat.
Und noch einige andere problematische Personen, die halt einfach jetzt die Gelegenheit
nutzen mit ihrem Einfluss, den sie durch ihr Geld bekommen haben,
sich die Welt so zusammenzubauen, wie ihnen das jetzt gerade gefällt.
Von irgendwie Kryptogeld als Staatsreserve und all so ein Unsinn bis hin zu
Freedom Cities, die sie jetzt einführen wollen, irgendwelche rechtsfreien Räume quasi,
wo so die Reichen wohnen und dann unberührt sind von irgendwelchen Gesetzen.
Also die leben einfach literally in einer anderen Welt.
Und das ist halt das, was sich dann an der Stelle der Öffentlichkeit gegenüber
gezeigt hat mit dieser Situation.
Also ich denke mal, dieses Treffen, diese Runde da im Oval Office,
das wird noch lange, lange, lange, lange,
lange Zeit als so ein Wendepunkt der internationalen geopolitischen Struktur
dieses Planetens und den Machtverhältnissen auf diesem Planeten genannt werden.
Und jetzt müssen wir erstmal gucken, was jetzt passiert und es passiert ja eine Menge.
Und zwar, dass ich jetzt, glaube ich, relativ klar, also ich würde nochmal meine
Einschätzung betonen, dass ich ernsthaft glaube,
dass mit einer solchen, also egal wie du als politische, als Staat deine Macht sichern möchtest,
langfristig kannst du das nur mit einer wie auch immer gearteten Verlässlichkeit tun.
Verlässlich, dass man weiß, keine Ahnung, deine Drohungen werden wahr oder nicht
oder deine Zusagen werden wahr
oder nicht, aber irgendeine Form der Verlässlichkeit muss da drin sein.
Und wenn du dich vollkommen erratisch gegenüber allen Ländern verhältst, dann kann das,
werden auf jeden Fall deine Kosten zur Zementierung deiner Macht steigen und nicht sinken.
Und das, was, also ich habe wirklich persönlich gerade als jemand,
dem gerade auch mal klar wird, wie viel von unserem...
Also von der Welt, in der du und ich leben dürfen,
bestimmt ist, von einer Verlässlichkeit der USA,
die eine Weltordnung hier dominiert, sei es positiv oder negativ,
wie man diese Weltordnung betrachtet oder Aspekte dieser Weltordnung betrachtet,
so ist sie in ihrer Stabilität auf jeden Fall durch die USA gesichert.
Und es mag auch sein, dass man vielleicht mittelfristig destabilisierte Weltordnung
und danach entstehende bessere Weltordnung bevorzugt, aber das,
was da gerade passiert, ist ja ein absoluter Sturm ins Ungewisse,
in eine Welt, in der auf einmal der US-amerikanische Präsident für die Autofirma
von seinem Buddy da irgendwie so ein Showlaufen veranstaltet.
Hast du dir das angeschaut?
Hat er da diese Teslas vorfahren lassen und hat im Pressetermin des Weißen Hauses
gesagt, wie geil diese Autos sind.
Und hatte irgendwie so ein Zettel in der Hand, Modell 3, das gelbe oder sowas.
Typisch mit Trumps großen, hast du das gesehen? Ja, wer ist für einen Witz gehalten?
Aber da hat dann irgendwie ein Associated Press Fotograf ein Foto gemacht,
wo er gerade sein Sprechzettel da in die Kamera hält.
Und dann stehen da die Preise dran und dann sagt er irgendwie,
jetzt hat das Weiße Haus noch irgendwie eine Starlink-Antenne auf dem Dach und so.
Also der verschleudert diese Position US-Präsident gerade irgendwie für Werbung
für irgendwie seinen komischen Kumpel da.
Es ist schlimmer als wir mit Anke Domscheit-Berg in der Sendung vor einem Monat.
Das ist wirklich unglaublich, ohne jeden Geschmack.
Also ich kann nur sagen, ich kriege da wirklich mit der Angst zu tun,
was erstmal die grundsätzliche Weltordnung angeht.
Nicht, dass ich die jetzt, bevor jetzt wieder alle sagen, ich wäre hier ein
US-amerikanischer Imperialist oder was nicht alles.
Aber es war schon ganz halbwegs in Ordnung.
Ein paar Jahrzehnte mit der Gewissheit zu leben,
dass jetzt ein europäischer Landkrieg erstmal nicht so einfach passieren wird
und dass bestimmte wirtschaftliche Verhältnisse, dass man zumindest damit rechnen kann, dass die,
also wirtschaftspolitische Verhältnisse,
man jetzt erstmal damit rechnen kann, dass die so bleiben.
Und dass auch eine Pandemie diese Welt in ihrer Stabilität, wie gesagt,
in ihren Feindschaften, wie auch in ihren Koalitionen, nicht aus den Angeln gehoben hat.
Aber natürlich ein völlig durchgeknallter Opa im Weißen Haus mit ein paar Technofaschisten,
das kann das natürlich schon machen.
Und vor allem das Vertrauen, wie gesagt, was da jetzt erschüttert wird, das ist irre.
Und jetzt plötzlich manifestieren sich natürlich auch, und da schließt sich
vielleicht, bevor jetzt die Sorge ist, dass wir den netzpolitischen Bogen nicht
mehr hinkriegen, Da schließt sich natürlich auch ein Kreis,
nicht nur was die militärische Bündnisse der Bundesrepublik Deutschland angeht,
sondern auch was die digitale Souveränität dieses Landes angeht.
Das über Jahrzehnte zwar.
Theoretische Einwände verstanden hat, was es bedeutet, seine komplette Daten
in irgendeine US-Cloud zu schieben,
aber jetzt mal tatsächlich mit einer Realität konfrontiert ist, dass das sehr schnell,
sehr, sehr, sehr ins Auge gehen kann.
Bevor wir vielleicht auf diese ganzen Cloud-Aspekte und so weiter kommen,
lass uns ruhig nochmal kurz bei unmittelbaren Auswirkungen haben,
weil da spielt es auch schon noch mit rein.
Ich meine, drei Tage nachdem das passiert war im Oval Office irgendwie hat quasi
die EU sich zusammengesessen,
gab es schnell mal ein Treffen, ich glaube alle Außenminister war es und dann
wurde auch bald verkündet so, okay, Europa kündigt jetzt die Wiederbewaffnung
an. Also so krass war das.
Also sie haben sich da im Oval Office angeschrien. Drei Tage später wacht Europa
auf aus diesem Traum der letzten 80 Jahre, die irgendwie ganz gut funktioniert haben.
Und stellt fest, dass man dann doch eher nackt dasteht und jetzt in irgendeiner
Form sich unabhängig machen kann.
Also das ist ja sagen wir mal jetzt so das große Thema.
Wir müssen unsere Abhängigkeiten reduzieren. Und da geht es ja schon bei diesem Rüstungsthema los,
dass jetzt zum Beispiel alle befürchten, dass die Amerikaner in der Lage werden,
ihnen einfach die Waffen auszuschalten.
Also verschiedenste Länder, auch Deutschland haben zum Beispiel diese F-35,
derzeit das modernste Kriegsflugzeug oder gilt zumindest als das modernste Kriegsflugzeug,
Bestellt und jetzt haben sie natürlich alle Angst, dass wenn sie irgendwie beim
Amerikaner kaufen und der Amerikaner ist gerade so mit,
ja irgendwie mir passt deine Nase nicht,
dass dann dieses ganze schöne teure Gerät nicht mehr funktioniert.
Die einzigen, die sowas übrigens von vornherein mit eingepreist haben bei ihrem
Kauf, waren übrigens die Israelis.
Die haben auch ganz viele von diesen F-35, aber die sind eben nicht abhängig
von den amerikanischen Support-Zentren und von Software-Updates und so weiter,
sondern haben halt darauf bestanden, dass wenn sie das kaufen,
dann brauchen sie das auch wie alles in ihrem Land.
Und dieser Gedanke, dieser Resilienz,
die jetzt erforderlich ist und nach dieser Zeitenwende,
also das ist jetzt mal wirklich eine Zeitenwende Also Scholz hatte eigentlich
schon recht mit der Zeitenwende, er hat bloß danach nichts zu dem Thema weiter
beigetragen Also das waren jetzt drei,
vergebene Jahre Frankreich hat ja schon länger dieses Lied gesungen und die
Franzosen galten ja eigentlich immer so als die Exzentriker,
wo immer alle gesagt haben so, ja ihr und so.
Die Franzosen waren nicht in der NATO. Die Franzosen haben auch keine Militärtechnik
der Amerikaner und so weiter.
Die haben alles selber gebaut und haben eigene Atomwaffen und jetzt stehen sie
halt da und sagen, okay, dann können wir euch ja jetzt erstmal beschützen.
Und das, ja, da haben sie einen Punkt. Das ist halt so ein Ding.
Und jetzt werden wir, glaube ich, sehen, wie diese ganze Logik.
Wie die Franzosen eine Cloud bauen, damit wir da unsere Daten haben.
Also zumindest in Teilbereichen sind sie schon mal deutlich viel weiter als
Deutschland auf jeden Fall.
Weil ich glaube, Deutschland steht da wirklich jetzt besonders schlecht da in diesem ganzen Spiel.
Die Briten hängen natürlich noch sehr am amerikanischen Tropf,
haben halt viel Technik und haben sich da immer sicher gewähnt,
dass das Verhältnis zu den USA quasi unkündbar ist.
Und das scheint sich jetzt auch gerade zu ändern.
Meine persönliche Hoffnung ist natürlich, dass im Zuge dieser ganzen Ereignisse,
und der zu erwartenden Verschärfung sich dann vielleicht auch mal das britische
Volk ein bisschen an den Kopf packt und sagt,
vielleicht war einfach das mit dem Brexit eine Scheißidee und wir machen das
jetzt mal wieder rückgängig.
So weit sind wir glaube ich noch nicht, aber es könnte mittelfristig darauf hinsteuern.
Ja, und ansonsten werden wir sehen, was jetzt Phase ist.
Auf jeden Fall ist diese ganze Überlegung der Resilienz ein Thema.
Und es leitet natürlich das auch ein. Mir ist jetzt so ein Artikel hier vor die Nase gekommen.
Aus Amsterdam. Die Stadt Amsterdam hat uns schon mal bekannt gegeben, dass sie.
Diese ganzen Abhängigkeiten von amerikanischen Datenanbietern gerne rückgängig
machen möchte und da auf eine neue Strategie setzt.
Und wenn man sich das so mal durchliest, was sie da ankündigen und welche Punkte
sie da aufbringen, dann ist das schon wirklich bemerkenswert.
Also wie Amsterdam, auch die Niederländer und Europa sagen, sie müssen digital unabhängiger werden.
Wir verlassen uns auf digitale Dienste großer ausländischer Technologieunternehmen
für Navigation, Online-Zahlung und die Suche nach einer Pflege und was weiß ich.
Also Daten und wir kündigen jetzt hier einen Kurswechsel an,
egal ob es um Privatsphäre oder nationale Sicherheit geht.
Wir können es uns nicht mehr leisten, stark von einigen großen amerikanischen
Technologieunternehmen abhängig zu sein.
Es muss einen Plan B geben, um zu verhindern, dass die US-Regierung oder Big
Tech alles für uns bestimmt.
Lässt sich wie ein CCC-Presse in Mitteilungen.
So, Investitionen in digitale Unabhängigkeit.
Digitale Unabhängigkeit als neuer Standard im Einkauf, Kontrolle über die eigenen
Daten, Verwendung offener Software und eine neue Social Media der Strategie und so weiter.
Das ließ sich bemerkenswert.
Ja, wäre schön. Also spätestens jetzt wird sich natürlich nochmal richtig besonders
rächen, dass Deutschland, oder vielleicht, ich sag mal so,
Deutschland hat auch noch ein Ass im Ärmel, das kein anderer hat, Tim.
Was? Deutschland?
Ja.
Na, was denn? SAP, oder? Fax, Fax.
Fax.
Ey, das hat keiner. Das hat keiner. Das ist wie, weißt du? Das hat keiner.
Da können wir ungestört, oh, da ist der Feind, das kann der überhaupt nicht.
Solche Geräte hat der nicht.
Wir können einfach wieder, wir können die Fax, also Digitalisierung ist in Deutschland,
immerhin noch eine Option.
Das ist ein Pfad, der steht modernen Nationen und deren Staatswesen nicht mehr offen.
Ja gut, aber jetzt müssen wir natürlich auch mal realistisch drauf schauen.
Was ist denn realistisch? Und ich würde sagen, realistisch ist nicht viel.
Leider nicht.
Wenn du dir große Unternehmen anschaust, die stecken so tief im Arsch von Microsoft.
Also selbst wenn es heute eine Alternative gäbe, die es nicht gibt,
Sich da rauszulösen, ist ein Jahrzehnteprojekt.
Also die Abhängigkeiten von Software, die Abhängigkeiten von Datenspeichern.
Es ist gar nicht mehr nur so die Cloud. Cloud ist eigentlich wahrscheinlich
noch das Einfachste, was du irgendwie machen kannst.
Aber Betriebssysteme und so weiter. Man muss jetzt vielleicht auch nicht zu paranoid werden.
Ich glaube jetzt nicht, dass irgendwie alle Microsoft-Windows-Systeme morgen
anfangen, für Trump zu werben.
Also man kann es dabei natürlich auch ein bisschen übertreiben.
Aber grundsätzlich ist natürlich auch klar, dass es diese Richtungsänderung
grundsätzlich jetzt schon mal braucht.
Auf jeden Fall für Aspekte nationaler Sicherheit,
also wo es wirklich um kritische Infrastruktur geht, Kritis und natürlich alles,
was irgendwie mit Data-Sharing auch zu tun hat etc.
Das muss natürlich alles auf den Prüfstand und da bin ich mir auch relativ sicher,
dass da die Gespräche bestimmt schon längst begonnen haben. Aber mittelfristig
muss man natürlich auch über andere Softwarearchitekturen sich Gedanken machen.
Nur das ist halt der Vorsprung der Amerikaner in dem Bereich ist,
das kann man doch nicht mal Vorsprung nennen. Also es ist einfach eine einzigartige
Stellung, die sie dort haben.
Überhaupt niemand in der Lage ist, das auch nur ansatzweise zu replizieren,
was amerikanische Software quasi für eine Rolle hat heutzutage.
Es ist einfach unkopierbar.
Also damit muss man natürlich die Bereiche anschauen, also ich denke wir haben
da den Enterprise-Bereich wo du Microsoft Windows,
Active Directory den ganzen dann den ganzen Office 365 oder Microsoft 365 heißt jetzt Kram, der,
sicherlich für eine Studentin noch mit starken Alternativen,
wie beispielsweise LibreOffice versehen ist, was aber,
in einem Enterprise-Umfeld oder so nicht ernsthaft,
mit den Kollaborationsmöglichkeiten und Integrationen, die so eine Microsoft
Suite bietet, konkurrieren kann.
Da gibt es Möglichkeiten, also es stimmt schon, man kann dann da jetzt irgendwie
so Open-Source-Software benutzen.
Und das funktioniert auch alles. Aber da müssen wir dann mal schon realistisch
sagen, dass das nicht so einfach wird, dahin zu kreieren.
Das ist ein Traumgebilde. Also davon kann man sich einfach trennen.
Das ist nicht so, dass du jetzt irgendwie Word gegen irgendein Open-Source-Tool
austauscht und dann hast du da eine Lösung gefunden.
Sondern da ist ja eine, Da sind ja Myriaden an Softwarepaketen und Architekturen
dahinter von weiteren Firmen, zahlreichen Firmen, Enterprise,
Software, die für Windows gemacht ist.
Du kannst darauf nicht verzichten. Du kannst dein Unternehmen,
kannst ja nicht sagen, ich nehme jetzt am Softwarebereich nicht mehr teil, weil USA.
Das ist vollkommen unrealistisch. Das ist überhaupt nicht vorstellbar.
Also, okay, das,
Ich denke, man muss ja schon sagen, es gibt für jede Anforderung,
die du in der IT hast, sei es eine Office-Suite, sei es eine Kollaboration,
sei es File-Sharing, sei es Video-Conferencing,
es gibt das alles auch in Open-Source-Lösungen.
Das heißt nicht, dass man sich aus der Softwarewelt verabschiedet, diese zu nutzen.
Aber viele Unternehmen haben eben vor 20 Jahren die Entscheidung getroffen,
das nicht zu tun. Ja, also es geht, es gibt natürlich, nächstes Jahr ist auch
das Jahr von Linux on the Desktop.
Das ist alles, es ist alles möglich und es gibt natürlich auch einige wenige, die das getan haben.
Und diese wenigen haben einige Vorteile.
Erstens merken sie jetzt langsam die Kostenvorteile, dass sie,
so ein Microsoft-Abonnement wird ja nicht günstiger.
Und sie merken jetzt, dass sie diese Migrationskosten nicht haben und dass sich
der Souveränitätsgedanke, in den sie vor vielen Jahren mal investiert haben,
sicherlich auch mit hohen Einrichtungsproduktivitätsanpassungskosten,
oder sonstigen.
Oder vielleicht auch, weil sie nicht ein hardcore durchdigitalisiertes Unternehmen
sind, was jeden Scheiß an irgendeine Entra-ID anknoten muss.
Die haben jetzt gut Kacken, aber ein Unternehmen, das sich den normalen Weg,
der in den letzten 10, 15 Jahren der vorgezeichnete Nobody Ever Got Fired for
Buying IBM or Microsoft war,
denen bietet sich für das, was sie jetzt in Prozessen in einem größeren Unternehmen
vielleicht etabliert haben, keine Alternative mehr.
Da kannst du auch nicht migrieren oder sonst was. Die hängen da jetzt einfach drin.
Oder keine kurzfristige Alternative. wir haben ja als CCC und auch hier im Podcast
schon sehr regelmäßig auch davor gewarnt und gesagt, dass wir eben abschneiden,
wir haben ja auch ähnliche Diskussionen,
in Deutschland ja,
über chinesisches Netzwerkequipment geführt.
Übrigens auch da habe ich als Sachverständiger zum IT-Sicherheitsgesetz 2 durchaus
mich zu eingelassen und habe auch hier im Podcast schon damals gesagt,
das Problem ist nicht, ob man der chinesischen Technik vertrauen kann oder nicht.
Das Problem ist, dass wir keine eigene mehr haben.
Wenn wir die deutschen Mobilfunknetze damit bauen, gibt es keine Alternativen mehr.
Weil aus Europa. Gibt es nicht. Es gibt, Vorsicht, hier kommt meine berufliche
Tätigkeit ein bisschen in Konflikt, einen Interessenkonflikt,
den ich öffentlich machen muss.
Ich bin ja mit Open-Ran-Infrastrukturen beschäftigt.
Da gibt es Unternehmen, die so etwas bauen, die also im Prinzip sagen, wir bauen den ganzen,
wir bauen komplette Mobilfunknetze ohne Huawei, indem man das alles in Containern
auf x86 Hardware baut und laufen lässt.
Das gibt es funktionierend in Deutschland.
Unternehmen, die sowas machen, wären Rakuten und Marvenir, die im weitesten
Sinne quasi einen kompletten Technologiestack.
Kontainerisiert zum Ausrollen auf dem x86-Bereich deiner Wahl gebaut haben.
Aber das wird der Deutschen Telekom jetzt auch nicht mehr helfen.
Die zu einem sehr großen Anteil eben dieses Netz mit Huawei-Komponenten gebaut hat.
Alle anderen Anbieter, ähnlich hohe Anteile. Das nur, es gibt diese Alternativen.
Ich kann mir auch vorstellen, dass das Mobilfunknetz in Deutschland,
was sich entschieden hat, Huawei frei zu bauen, jetzt gerade durchaus darüber freut.
Vielleicht auch zittert, weil Marvin hier, glaube ich, ein US-Unternehmen ist.
Ja, sicherlich gibt es irgendwo immer wieder für einzelne Bereiche gibt es irgendwelche
Lösungen, wo du auf das eine oder andere verzichten kannst, aber im Großen und
Ganzen ist das alles nicht da.
Und es ist absolut unrealistisch, das alles innerhalb irgendeiner absehbaren
Zeit irgendwie entflochten zu bekommen.
Also nicht… Ja, das ist der da.
Dafür ist das Loch, was wir uns gegraben haben.
Ja, also nicht vor 2040 sehe ich da überhaupt irgendeinen Pfad irgendwo hinzeigen,
weil das ist ja nicht nur die Sache von Software und was du irgendwo installierst,
was du an Bildung und ausgebildeten Fachkräften, was die kennen,
womit die schon immer gearbeitet haben und so weiter,
das trägt sich ja Jahrzehnte nach vorne.
Und bis du da überhaupt erstmal ein anderes Mindset reinbekommen hast,
bis du überhaupt mal anfängst auch die Bildung ins Land zu tragen,
in Europa mal wieder ein Bildungssystem zu etablieren, was halt auch irgendwie
Leute und auch Firmen hervorbringt,
die in der Lage sind, so sustained eine neue Softwareindustrie zu begründen, die auch eigenständig,
unabhängig von dem Investitionsgeld von Silicon Valley überleben kann,
das wird einfach dauern.
Oh, okay, kommt noch was Positives. Ja, aber naja, ich meine,
ich sage ja nicht, es wird nie irgendwie möglich sein, aber man darf sich jetzt
nicht der Illusion hingeben, dass man jetzt irgendwo so den Schalter von US
auf EU umlegt und dann geht das schon,
sondern das ist halt ein langfristiges Projekt.
Du kannst ja auch nicht jetzt sagen, ja, wir machen jetzt mal Wiederbewaffnung
in Europa und nächstes Jahr sind wir fertig.
Nee, jetzt musst du erst mal fünf Jahre lang Fabriken aufbauen und einen Plan
haben und dich irgendwie mit 30 anderen Ländern in Europa einen Weg entwerfen,
ohne dass dann noch solche Vollpfosten wie die ungarische Regierung versucht,
die ganze Zeit Knüppel zwischen die Beine zu werfen, um da überhaupt erst mal auf den Weg zu kommen.
Und dann ist das etwas, was vielleicht in zehn Jahren erste Früchte tragen kann.
Klar, man kann hier und da mal schnell kurzfristige Entscheidungen machen,
Geld erstmal umlenken und Dinge auf den Weg bringen, aber das dauert.
Und genauso ist es auch bei Software und bei Systemen.
Da musst du überhaupt erstmal die Bedingungen schaffen.
Warum gehen denn alle immer in die USA?
Naja, weil du da ganz andere Arbeitsbedingungen hast, irgendwie ein Softwareunternehmen
mit Geld zu versorgen und du hast da die Investoren.
Allerdings, und jetzt, ich weiß nicht, ob das jetzt ein positiver Aspekt ist,
aber das ist, sagen wir mal, natürlich, eine Krise ist ja auch immer eine Chance.
Und jetzt haben wir eine Krise, eine ordentliche. Und die Krise besagt,
wir müssen uns auf uns besinnen, wir müssen irgendwie unsere eigenen Werkzeuge
schaffen, damit wir unabhängiger sind.
Wir werden nicht unabhängig sein, irgendwie in einem Bereich,
definierten, nahen Zukunftsmoment, aber man kann den Weg dahin bringen und das
ist halt jetzt das, was möglich ist, weil jetzt geht vielleicht eben auch das
europäische Geld nicht mehr in die USA,
was dann dort investiert, sondern es verbleibt dann in Europa und investiert
dann hier vielleicht auch mal in Deutschland,
vielleicht investiert man auch mal in Bildung in Deutschland,
das wäre auch mal ganz gut, da sehe ich nämlich durchaus ein Defizit.
Du musst ja nur mal anschauen, wie es irgendwie an Universitäten ist.
Du siehst ein Defizit?
Ja, du kriegst ja noch nicht mal die Leute, die da unterrichten,
bezahlen. Ja, also da fängt es ja schon an.
Geschweige denn, dass du auch nur anhaltsweise mit Curricula,
werben kannst, die mit dem amerikanischer Universitäten zu vergleichen sind, was Hightech betrifft.
Also das ist ja nochmal ein ganzer Rattenschwanz an Aspekten, der noch mitkommt.
Aber deswegen, das ist ein riesiger Tanker, der gerade in Richtung Westen unterwegs
war und der jetzt irgendwie wieder nach Osten fahren muss.
Und dauert einfach, bis so ein Tanker 180 Grad Wendungen gemacht hat.
Da ist sehr viel Trägheit in so einem System, in so viel Masse und da brauchst
du auch sehr viel Energie, um diese Masse in eine andere Richtung zu führen.
Das muss natürlich jetzt stattfinden. Und das sind natürlich dann solche Ankündigungen
wie Amsterdam, ist jetzt sozusagen erstmal….
Für den Mindset erstmal wichtig und an dem muss jetzt gearbeitet werden,
um einfach mittelfristig, langfristig dort Erfolge zu haben.
Und es ist ja auch nicht nur die USA, es ist halt auch China,
hast du jetzt schon angesprochen, das sind nun mal die beiden großen Pole dieser
Welt. Und das wird auch so bleiben für lange, lange Zeit.
Allein schon deshalb, weil China jetzt natürlich durch Trump auch klar die Nummer
eins werden wird auf dieser Welt.
Also es ist halt einfach, die agieren halt klug.
So, das, ja, die sind halt nicht, die haben halt keine Vollpfosten,
also man kann die chinesische Regierung sicherlich für einiges kritisieren,
aber bestimmt nicht dafür,
dass sie keine langfristigen Perspektiven hat.
Also wenn sie irgendwas gut können, dann sind es irgendwie langfristige Perspektiven
aufzeigen und diesen Plan zu verfolgen.
Allein der Weg der Elektrifizierung, den China jetzt eingeschlagen hat,
der ist ja so krass in seiner Dimension.
Und China wird es schaffen, sich bis Ende der 30er Jahre weitgehend von dem
Öl freigekauft zu haben. Warum?
Weil sie einfach in einer absurden Zahl Solar und Wind und andere Systeme für
die Energienutzung jetzt heranziehen und dort Kapazitäten aufbauen,
Bis sie diese ganzen Abhängigkeiten, die sie jetzt noch haben,
die sie jetzt noch brauchen,
nicht mehr haben.
Während wir halt hier immer noch irgendwie über Wärmepumpen diskutieren.
Und das ist vollkommen absurd.
Und ich meine, die USA wiederum graben sich meiner Meinung nach halt gerade das eigene Grab.
Also wenn sie den Trump nicht bald eingefangen bekommen,
dann ist natürlich der Niedergang der USA, ich weiß nicht, ob er unaufhaltsam
ist, aber auf jeden Fall ist er dann signifikant.
Also das wird die alte Macht der letzten Jahrzehnte, die werden sie verlieren.
Also hoffentlich, hoffentlich, ja.
Es wäre… Naja, das ist nicht unbedingt gut für uns, sagen wir es mal so.
Nö, das war bequemer, das war bequemer im kompletten, also das komplette Land
in jeglicher Substanz in den Arsch zu sparen.
Sowohl, also insbesondere was
die Bildung angeht, aber auch was in Infrastrukturen und Sonstiges angeht.
Die KUKA-Roboter auch noch den Chinesen zu verkaufen. Dieses Land steht ja nun
wirklich, stell dir mal vor, irgendwann gibt es eine Änderung der Physik und,
Verbrennungsmotor funktioniert nicht mehr.
Dann ist dieses Land hier innerhalb kürzester Zeit komplett erledigt.
Dieses Land steht wirklich sehr nackt da und hat sich enorm ausgeruht in einem
Natürlich auch in einem sehr attraktiven Angebot,
das sich in US-amerikanischer technischer Überlegenheit dargestellt hat und
auf die eigene Innovationskraft, auf die eigene Idee da mitzuspielen,
regelmäßig vollständig verzichtet.
Ich erinnere mich an Meredith, die bei uns in der Sendung war und dann sagte,
wie dann da irgendwie Pressetermine von irgendwelchen Europäern gemacht werden,
weil sie sagen, wir investieren jetzt 5 Millionen in AI oder so.
Oder auch sagst du, Leute, ihr habt einfach überhaupt keine Vorstellung.
Ihr wisst ja gar nicht, habt ihr mal aus dem Fenster geguckt?
Und das ist also wirklich...
Und da wäre es natürlich sehr schön, wenn dieser Weckruf jetzt gehört würde
und man wirklich erkennt, dass jetzt hier eine Zeitenwende ist.
Nicht, wir müssen mal was Schönes in der Presse sagen oder wir müssen zusehen,
dass wir uns mit dem Trump gutstellen, weil das kann sehr gut sein.
Und das wäre die, also das ist die Situation, die ich hoffe zu vermeiden,
dass demnächst die deutsche Bundeskanzlerin in zehn Jahren, dieses Experiment
mit den Männern wird sich ja nicht durchsetzen,
dass sie sich dann da demnächst auch von irgendeinem J.D.
Vance in zehn Jahren oder so auf diese Weise behandeln lassen muss.
Und dann einfach gucken muss, wer das weniger schlechte Angebot macht.
Ob China, Russland oder die USA sind.
Also das Konzept Bundeskanzlerin hatten wir ja schon 16 Jahre.
Das hat sich auch nicht gewährt.
Das hat uns dahingespart, ist richtig. Aber die hatte wenigstens Umgangsfonds.
Ja, gut.
Welche positiven Möglichkeiten gibt es? oder welche positiven Potenziale gibt es.
Den europäischen Bereich in seiner Autonomie und seiner Resilienz zu stärken,
ist ein riesiger Markt an Geld, was wir gerade nach China und USA geben.
Da kannst du einige sehr schöne Wohlstandsquellen in Europa bauen,
wenn du sagst, das mach mal jetzt selber.
Da wirst du natürlich dieses Vierteljahrhundert-Brain-Drain in Richtung USA,
die entsprechenden Technologie-Vorsprünge,
die es dort und in China gibt, einzuholen.
Da musst du richtig reinbuttern, da müsste man eventuell mal so eine Schuldenbremse
für ein bisschen lockern,
um da vorsichtig ein bisschen an der Schuldenbremse mal drehen,
um vielleicht ein Vierteljahrhundert Rückschritt aufzuholen,
aber da winken natürlich durchaus sehr große Profitmöglichkeiten,
wenn man die entsprechend fördert.
Gleichzeitig gibt es jede Menge hochqualifizierte Menschen, die.
Hoffentlich bald aus den USA auswandern, weil da auch innergesellschaftlich
jetzt ein Wind weht, der es zunehmend unangenehm machen wird,
in diesem Lande zu leben.
Wir denken an die vielen Trans-Personen beispielsweise, die im Tech-Bereich
sind und sagen, naja, okay,
warum nicht mal Berlin oder so, da kommen die Ersten jetzt gerade an.
Da könnte man mal schauen, ob man nicht deren Bildung und Skills bei uns anwenden kann.
Ich glaube schon, dass es da Potenziale gibt oder Europa mal wieder in der Wissenschaft
stärken, Forschung in Europa betreiben.
Ist ja etwas, da sind wir ja noch halbwegs da, nur in dem Umsetzen der Technologien dann nicht mehr so.
Also es gibt hier schon durchaus ein Potenzial, in einem kaputtgesparten Land
gibt es immer ein Potenzial.
Und das wäre schon sehr schön, wenn man diesen Spirit auch mal in dieses Land kriegen könnte.
Zu sagen, ja klar, machen wir es jetzt selber. Ja klar, wird das schmerzhaft.
Aber wir haben auch echt keinen Bock irgendwie, ich meine, guck dir diese Vöglein da mal an.
Also guck dir diesen Trump an, guck dir diesen Musk an, guck dir diesen Vance an,
also du kannst ja nun nicht ernsthaft und dann in diese fürchterliche Situation,
wie sie da alle stehen und Bill Gates und wie heißt der,
Mark Zuckerberg und alle standen sie da zur Inauguration, haben nur Kohle aus
der Firma oder aus ihrem eigenen Geld geholt, um denen in den Arsch zu kriechen.
Das ist schon das Bild sollte man nicht vergessen, wenn in drei Wochen eine
andere Sau durchs Dorf getrieben wird.
Sondern das muss man sich jetzt die nächsten 10, 15 Jahre vor Augen halten.
Und hier einen stabilen, selbstgenügsamen, solidarischen Binnenmarkt in Europa hochziehen.
Mit den ganzen Potenzialen, auf die diese USA da gerade verzichten möchten.
Ja, also ich meine, es wird definitiv, also man muss, man könnte davon profitieren,
dass in den USA jetzt sehr viel, vieles unattraktiver wird.
Also Geldflüsse habe ich schon erwähnt, das weiß ich noch nicht so ganz genau,
wie sich das entwickeln wird.
Da muss es glaube ich noch sehr viel schlimmer werden, bevor die USA aufhört,
dieser Finanzmagnet zu sein.
Aber wenn du jetzt irgendwie alle coolen Entwickler nach Berlin holen willst ja,
dann sollte man vielleicht hier mal dafür sorgen, dass so viele Clubs schließen
müssen irgendwie in Berlin ja, weil mit dieser,
drögen Antikulturpolitik, die wir jetzt haben, wird natürlich Berlin auch nicht
besonders interessant für junge Leute,
also das ist ja so ein bisschen auch das andere Problem, was dabei ist,
dass einfach hier auch einfach konsequent alles kaputt gemacht worden ist und
weiterhin kaputt gemacht wird, was irgendwie nennenswert ist.
Kulturell und auch an vielen anderen Ebenen. Berlin ist ja jetzt auch ein totales
Trauerspiel, was das betrifft.
Aber klar, also es ist...
Also stimmt, aber warst du mal in Baden-Württemberg?
Naja Den Aufkleber muss man ja Scheiße hier,
Also ich hoffe Ich kann mir einfach nur wünschen, dass dieser Weckruf irgendwie,
ankommt und jetzt in eine positive Energie gelenkt wird, weil da kannst du eine
ganze Menge positive Energie rausholen.
Ja, also ich hoffe, also die Hoffnung stirbt ja wie bekannt immer zuletzt.
Und ich hatte auch ein schönes Gespräch mit einem Menschen in Taiwan,
wo wir so Gott und die Welt unterhalten haben und es war interessant,
er erzählte mir so, ja, dann überlegt er auch noch ein Auto zu kaufen,
wir haben uns über alles mögliche unterhalten und,
sagte dann auch so, ja, hier Mercedes, das wäre ja auch ganz toll, zeigte da so ein Auto.
Ich fand das jetzt nicht so interessant, aber man merkte so richtig, Deutschland,
im Ausland hat immer noch diesen Mythos von funktioniert alles so super und
wir kriegen irgendwie alles auf der Kette und was zur Qualität und all das.
Und dann habe ich mir irgendwie erzählt, wie das so ist in Berlin.
Was hast du ihm erzählt?
Ich habe ihm mal erzählt.
Wenn er versucht hat.
Einen Termin zu bekommen, um einen internationalen Führerschein zu beantragen.
So, dass ich dann irgendwie auf der Webseite Ich kann schon verstehen.
Dass du gerne so ein Auto hältst.
Aber dafür brauchst du einen Führerschein. Der nächste drei Monate die zur Verfügung
stehen, um sowas dann auch zu machen, weil das natürlich online alles nicht geht.
Und dann habe ich ihn gefragt, ob er sich vorstellen kann, wie viele freie Termine
da waren in den nächsten drei Monaten?
Ja, die Antwort hat ihn dann schon.
Dann hat er gefragt, was der Termin ist.
Naja, also es ist auch schwierig, das alles zu erklären, dass man sowas überhaupt braucht.
Aber dass dann halt irgendwie genau kein einziger Termin war in den nächsten
drei Monaten, mit dem man das machen konnte, das hat ihn dann doch schon ein bisschen überrascht.
Also das ist, ja okay, ich will jetzt nicht wieder diese alte Leier aufziehen.
Zeitenwende. Also auf jeden Fall, ich finde es,
Irgendwo auch ermutigend, also so schlimm das jetzt mit den USA ist und es ist schlimm.
Es ist vor allem schlimm für die USA und was schlimm für die USA ist,
ist halt auch erstmal für den Rest der Welt weitgehend schlimm.
Da gibt es nicht viel drüber zu freuen und ich zucke auch jeden Tag bei jeder
Meldung wieder zusammen, weil es ja sozusagen jetzt ein Staccato geworden ist.
Jetzt wird irgendwie Voice of America abgeschaltet, keine Ahnung.
Mittlerweile handeln sie ja auch gegen das Gesetz. Die Gerichte sagen,
nee, dürft ihr nicht machen, die machen es dann trotzdem.
Also sie schlittern jetzt quasi in so eine echte Verfassungskrise zu.
Und wenn du dir nochmal anguckst, was so die Opposition, die sogenannte in den
USA gerade so leistet, Katastrophe, ja, gar nichts.
Ja.
Weil das auch so eine totale Gerontokratie geworden ist.
Also einfach auch, da laufen ja nur noch so 80-Jährige rum und da kann halt
irgendwie nichts passieren.
Also die USA hat es halt auch geschafft, sich irgendwie total zu verfetten in
ihrem System und es so weit auf die Spitze zu treiben,
dass sie einfach diese Resilienz auch nicht haben, sich dagegen zu wehren.
Und dasselbe Problem haben wir natürlich jetzt hier auch mit der AfD und den
ganzen anderen Spinnern.
Und jetzt hast du eben dann auch noch so ein permanentes Kommunikationsgewitter
in diesen Gesellschaftsmedien,
wo einfach Leute komplett bildungsfrei einfach irgendeinen Scheiß behaupten und glauben.
Und alle glauben irgendwas und keiner weiß mehr irgendetwas.
Und das ist einfach keine gute Situation, in der man ist.
Und deswegen muss ich sagen, man kann, das ist jetzt wirklich ein großer Bogen,
den ich da schlage, aber so Zentrum für politische Bildung, das kam ja auch
in den Kommentaren so, ja, und ihr macht ja das und was hat es denn gebracht?
Was ihr da macht.
Meinst du Zentrum für politische Bildung oder Zentrum für politische Schönheit?
Zentrum für politische Schönheit, selbstverständlich. Zentrum für politische
Bildung, da frage ich mich auch, was es denn gebracht hat.
Ja, ich komme da auch.
Und klar, diese Position kann man haben, auch wenn es ein bisschen,
finde ich, die Sache umdreht.
Aber ein Prozent von dem Mut und der Energie, die diese Truppe täglich da an
den Tag legt in unserer Politik und wir werden schon ganz woanders.
Aber es ist einfach eine totale Schlaffheit und Mutlosigkeit und Uninspiriertheit
und Inkompetenz, die mich wahnsinnig macht.
Also mich macht es wirklich fertig, wie doof alle sind.
Es ist nicht zu ertragen. Es ist wirklich schlimm, grauenhaft.
Und jetzt stell dir das mal für mich vor, ich finde ja sogar dich doof.
Das ist eine totale Kaskade. Alle doof.
Ja, aber es ist einfach Hoffnungslosigkeit macht sich da in mir breit,
weil wir nicht in der Lage sind, uns aufzuraffen und deswegen wiederum trotz all dem,
ist dieser Moment auch eine Chance, weil es jetzt die Energie gibt,
dass alle anfangen, sich klar zu werden, so, ah, okay, ja, läuft nicht gut bei uns im Staat.
Sollte man vielleicht mal was dagegen tun?
Wir haben ein Problem mit irgendwie Social Media und ungebildeten Leuten.
Sollte man vielleicht mal was dagegen tun? Ja, wir haben irgendwie Obdachlose auf den Straßen.
Sollte man vielleicht mal was dagegen tun? Wir müssen da einfach mal aufwachen
und auch mal wirklich was tun und nicht immer irgendwas fordern und wünschen
und am Ende ist keiner bereit,
auch nur einen Zentimeter zurückzuweichen,
wenn es ihnen an die eigenen Bründe geht. Das ist das Kernproblem.
Und diese Verfettung, die die USA hat und die sie so wehrlos macht,
das haben wir halt auch teilweise in Deutschland.
Also unser föderales System, okay, ich weiß, das ist mal irgendwann mal so designt
worden, um irgendwie die Übernahme des Staates zu verhindern.
Schönes Ziel, aber ich glaube im Wesentlichen verhindert dieses föderale System
derzeit einfach nur, dass wir überhaupt in irgendeiner Form noch vorankommen.
Und wie gut das mit der Resilienz gegen Rechts funktioniert, sehen wir ja auch.
Nicht gut. Und von daher sind da auch Reformen fällig und dazu braucht es aber
eine gesamtgesellschaftliche Anstrengung,
damit auch mal in der politischen Klasse ein paar Leute an den Start kommen,
die was reißen können in der Hinsicht.
Und da bin ich dann aber auch gerade mit der aktuellen Wahl nur begrenzt glücklich.
Und keine Ahnung, ob die CDU noch in der Lage ist, die Kurve zu kriegen.
Aber wenn die jetzt mit März dieselbe Show abziehen wie in den letzten zwei
Dekaden, dann Gute Nacht, Deutschland.
Dann können wir das komplett vergessen. Mit SPD brauchen wir,
glaube ich, gar nicht drüber reden.
Die haben jetzt drei Jahre lang gezeigt, dass sie irgendwie im Zweifelsfall
einfach auch gerne gar nichts tun.
Und dass sie dann vor allem, nachdem sie dermaßen verkacken,
fällt denen nichts besseres ein,
als den Lars Klingbeil und die Saskia Esken zu sagen, ja hör mal,
jetzt haben wir aber hier einen ganz klaren Führungsanspruch innerhalb dieser
Partei. Das ist erbärmlich.
Da kann man sich mal anschauen, wie in anderen Parteien damit umgegangen wird.
Mit so einer krachenden Wahlliderlage, dass dann auf einmal spritziges neues Personal kommt.
Uiuiui, nachher machen die es noch besser als ich.
Sie haben jetzt wieder Ihre Chance, es besser zu machen.
Das werden wir ja sehen. meine Hoffnung, also ich würde jetzt kein Geld wetten
auf die SPD und bei der CDU muss ich sagen, also wenn an der CDU hängt es jetzt.
Wenn die CDU wirklich bereit ist, diesen Kulturkampf,
diesen Republican-Style Kulturkampf zu führen und wenn sie.
Weiterhin diese Märchen der letzten 20 Jahre erzählen, dann wird es nichts werden.
Dann ist einfach Zeitenwende Deutschland, dann nimmt Deutschland einfach nicht
mehr aktiv am Geschehen teil.
Also wenn sie da nicht komplette 180 Grad Wende hinlegen, dann sorry,
aber das wir haben ja gesehen, wohin das geführt hat.
Ich meine, was hat denn die CDU in diesen 16 Jahren Merkel irgendwie vorangebracht?
Irgendwas Außenpolitik? Gar nichts. Energie, gar nichts.
Digitalisierung, überhaupt nichts. Nichts. Also weniger als nichts.
Ich finde, das ist einfach gemessen an dem, die Fortschritte,
die alle anderen machen, sind wir eigentlich straight in die Vergangenheit. Also, ne?
Und das ist sehr ärgerlich, ja?
Also ich weiß nicht, ob jetzt hier irgendwie Leute zuhören, die in irgendeiner
Form bei der CDU sind oder so, da soll es ja angeblich immer auch immer mal
junge Leute geben, die moderne Ideen haben und so, hört man mal.
Ja, die altern dann nur sehr schnell.
Ja, die altern dann nur sehr schnell, ja, so wie der Amthor. Und, aber...
Jetzt seid ihr am Zug. Wenn ihr das jetzt verkarkt, dann war es das.
Das ist jetzt echt der letzte, also wenn man diesen Moment nicht aufnimmt,
hier wirklich mal zu Reformen zu kommen und mal auch eine Aufbruchsstimmung
zu erzeugen, die ja komplett weg ist,
ja, dann weiß ich auch nicht mehr. Weil Deutschland ist auch nicht bereit,
irgendwie so eine Leute zu wählen offensichtlich.
Also ich will es jetzt auch nicht nur auf die Politik schieben,
sondern das Problem sind wir schon als Gesellschaft insgesamt.
Und ja, keine Ahnung, ich reg mich nur auf.
Also was machen wir jetzt? Wir sehen zu, dass wir fördern die europäische.
Also deutsche und europäische, also deutsch kannst du vergessen,
du wirst schon auf europäischer Ebenen machen.
Unabhängigkeit, Resilienz, Eigenständigkeit. Ich glaube schon,
dass von, wenn du jetzt mal anschaust, Europa, USA,
China, Russland, dass Europa auch wenn in Berlin 20 Clubs geschlossen haben, immer noch das,
angenehmste Lebensmodell anbietet, wenn du dir auf dieser Erde einen Platz suchen möchtest.
Kanada ist natürlich noch hart, aber es wird ja bald genauso wie Grönland dann USA sein.
Aber Europa hat schon noch einen ganz guten Stand.
Und dieser internationale Stand auf dem Planeten hat sich jetzt erstmal rein
politisch verbessert, seitdem die USA jetzt ganz offen in den Faschismus abdriften.
Daraus kann man was machen. Mit diesem Freiheitsgefühl kann man arbeiten.
Mit dem Wetter im Süden Europas auch.
Und mit den, wie gesagt, Möglichkeiten. Ich hoffe, wenn...
Also Länder, die weit zurück sind oder bei denen viel zerstört wurde,
da muss man halt auch sehr viel aufbauen und das bietet ökonomische Möglichkeiten.
Die Frage ist, kriegst du jetzt einen Spirit hin,
dass dieses Land das versteht und macht und sagt,
schaffe, schaffe, IT-Infrastruktur baue oder was auch immer hier an Opportunities besteht.
Und dieses Potenzial jetzt zu heben in einem solidarischen Gedanken,
in einem auch ökonomischen Gedanken und in gesellschaftlichen Gedanken zu sagen,
hey, jo geil, die ganze Welt ist kacke, hier ist es noch nicht kacke.
Bei uns steht nur das Risiko mit 20 Prozent im Bundestag und mit 70 Prozent vor der Tür in Polen.
Aber noch können wir. Ja.
Also anders sehe ich es auch nicht, aber die Potenziale sind ja nun mal da.
Ja, die Potenziale sind da, da müssen sie auch genutzt werden.
Wenn ich jetzt nicht ganz viel Geld hätte, um in IT zu investieren,
was ich nicht habe, ja, also...
Na, weil du dein ganzes Geld in IT investiert hast.
It wächst.
So teuer alles.
Also ich meine, wo würdest du hin investieren, wenn du in Europa investieren würdest, in IT?
Wo hast du das Gefühl, wo am meisten bei rauskommt?
Müsste ich,
potenziell würde ich mich wahrscheinlich nach Norden orientieren.
Schweden, Dänemark oder sowas? Bevor jetzt als nächstes sich jemand über unsere
schlechten Investment-Tipps.
Es geht ja nicht um Investment im Sinne von viel Geld verdienen,
sondern Investment im Sinne von viel bewegen, also viel Erfolg haben mit diesem Investment.
Also ein Investment, was sozusagen auf Ergebnisse hin zielt.
Na, ich würde sagen Nummer 1 Ukraine.
Niederlande. Bitte?
Ukraine.
Achso. Gut, hatte ich jetzt Top-IT-Land.
Ja, super Programmierer, die kriegen das irgendwie hin. Ein Land im Krieg,
was besser funktioniert als Deutschland.
Also okay, ist vielleicht jetzt kein Wunder.
Als Deutschland im Frieden.
Ja, aber ich war in der Ukraine, das ist da einfach digitaler,
also deutlich mit großem Abstand.
Okay, das meinst du?
Ja, und es ist ja auch nichts Neues, dass in der Ukraine Software sozusagen
eine große Rolle spielt.
Das war schon immer so, das war schon vor 10, 20 Jahren so.
Könnte man vielleicht auch ein bisschen Dankbares Talent bekommen,
wenn man den Präsidenten halbwegs ordentlich behandelt und vielleicht dafür
sorgt, dass das Land jetzt nicht den Russen zum Fraß vorgeworfen wird.
Das würde auf jeden Fall auch helfen. Ich meine, das ist, finde ich,
jetzt ohnehin die Priorität Nummer eins für Europa ist halt erstmal das.
Die Russen zurückdrängen, Ukraine retten, das ist das Wichtigste.
Wenn wir das schaffen, dann haben wir ein europäisches, einigendes Projekt.
Parallel dazu Ungarn entweder rausschmeißen oder dafür sorgen,
dass dieser Orban wegkommt. Ja, also einfach da muss einfach jetzt dem Spuk
muss da ein Ende gemacht werden.
Dieses Geeire, das geht irgendwie gar nicht.
Und dann wird es natürlich auch nochmal sehr interessant werden,
was sozusagen die Nachfolgeorganisation der NATO sein wird.
Da werden wir auch über einige, ja, wird es auch einige schwierige Entscheidungen geben müssen,
weil Europa muss sich jetzt auch darüber im Klaren werden, wie man mit der Türkei
umgehen möchte, das lässt sich jetzt auch nicht mehr weiter ignorieren.
Also das wird auf jeden Fall eine spannende Zeit werden, aber was Deutschland
betrifft, muss ich sagen,
hier ist die Botschaft.
Goldene 20er, Tim, du bleibst bei den goldenen 20ern, nee, das mahne ich jetzt auch mal an.
Das könnte noch was werden.
Das könnte noch was werden, also da haben wir jetzt, da sehe ich jetzt einen
Winkel, den habe ich einige Zeit lang nicht gesehen.
Ja, okay.
Wir machen zeitnah wieder eine Sendung mit digitalen Themen.
Wir wollten uns das mal ein bisschen von der Seele reden.
Wir hoffen, dass wir erst in vier Jahren wieder hier eine Wahlempfehlung,
nee, erhoffen wir, das ist auch die Frage, Entschuldigung, das darf ich auch nicht sagen.
Wahlempfehlung, dass du eine abgeben willst oder dass es das zu den ersten vier Jahren sein wird.
Wahlempfehlung habe ich noch nie gegeben. Ich habe auch noch nie jemandem gesagt, was ich wähle.
Und das habe ich auch im Vorgespräch zu Tim gesagt. Ich glaube,
dass sehr viele Leute mit ihrer Einschätzung, welche, wie ich üblicherweise
wähle und wie ich bei dieser Wahl gewählt habe, falsch liegen würden.
Das ist ja auch nicht die größte Frage, die alle im Kopf haben. Was Linus wohl so wählt?
Naja, Hauptsache ihr wählt LNP und das ist die einzige Partei,
die euch zu interessieren hat.
Wir machen dann nächste Sendung wieder mal das Ding mit den Nachrichten.
Und dauert vielleicht auch gar nicht so lange bis zur nächsten Sendung. Gucke war man.
Und bis dahin würde ich sagen, wünschen wir euch eine entspannte Revolution.
Jetzt ruft der Brit Laffi auch noch zur Revolution auf.
Sonst wird das ja nichts. Insbesondere innerhalb der CDU. Das fände ich ganz gut.
Schauen wir mal, was dabei rauskommt.
So denn.
Bis bald. Tschüss.